TAKAKO AIKAWA: So I
believe language teaching
needs to take place
together with that culture
of that language.
And whenever we teach some,
like linguistics, patterns--
for instance, even
like greetings, OK?
The linguistics forms
are very simple,
but Japanese people always bow.
So whenever we teach
some grammar patterns,
we also teach,
say, body language.
And also like whenever
we introduce honorific,
we have to introduce
the society,
I mean the hierarchical
kind of structure
of the Japanese society.
We need to introduce
students the concept that we
have to show respect
toward the elderly.
So every linguistic
aspect involves
a cultural understanding.
So whenever possible, we
introduce culture together
with language.
Also textbook has
so-called culture note.
So each lesson has culture
note to introduce one aspect
of the Japanese culture.
For instance, Japanese
housing, Japanese food,
how to take off shoes,
something like this.